le burqini c'est pas un vêtement comme
un autre le burqini c'est un signe de
soumission de la femme le burqini
consiste à dire la femme est un objet
tentation et elle doit se couvrir elle
pas les hommes c'est un symbole de
l'islam politique
qu'un maire de la république en france
allez à ce point de communautarisme de
compromission par l'islam politique est
pour moi un acte qui est très grave qui
est en rupture totale avec toutes les
valeurs de la république qui me sont
chers et notamment la laïcité et donc je
ne veux pas détourner le regard je veux
pas qu'on soit dans la lâcheté et qu'on
fasse semblant de ce dur véloce et une
décision d'un maire en france c'est un
signe d'un certain nombre d'élus qui
aujourd'hui pour acheter des voix ont
fait le choix de faire des pactes avec
l'islam politique
et moi en tant que président de région
j'ai toujours été très clair je ne
l'accepterai pas et on ne saura pas
complice de sang je le dis très
calmement très sereinement mais avec une
grande fermeté si l'amérique grenoble
devaient s'engager dans cette voie nous
nous cesserions tous travaillent avec le
maire de grenoble parce que je pense
qu'il faut être capable un moment de
dire stop tout n'est pas acceptable dans
la république française